لدينا تطور ميداني متعلق باعلان وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه مقتل جندي اسرائيلي
واصابه عدد اخر في معارك القطاع عرز ما
عندك
وليد نعم هذا الجندي اعلن انه قتل في
معارك بجنوب قطاع غزه وان ثلاثه اخرين
بينهم ضابط قد اصيبوا بجراح في هذه
المعارك وهو ما رفع مجمل عدد الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين الذين قتلوا منذ
طوفان الاقصى والحرب على غزه التي تدخل
اليوم يومها ال 107 الى
531 ومن بينهم
202 قتلوا منذ بدايه الحرب البريه على غزه
في ال 26 من اكتوبر بالاضافه اليهم هناك
16 جنديا وضابطا اصيبوا بجراح خلال ال
ساعه الماضيه في معارك متفرقه في ارجاء
قطاع غزه بمعنى انها تشمل ايضا منطقه
شمالي قطاع غزه التي شهدت بعض الاشتباكات
خاصه في مناطق بيت حنون و بيت لاهيا وايضا
جباليا في الشمال لكن المعارك الضاريه
الاساسيه هي في منطقه خانيونس على وجه
الخصوص والمناطق المحيطه بها مثل بني
سهيلا والكاره وعبس هذه المناطق هي التي
تشهد القتال الضاري وهو ما تقول اسرائيل
بانها تواجه فيه مقاومه شديده تحديدا من
كتائب القسام وكذلك باقي قوى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتقول بانها قد ضبطت شب كات
كبيره للانفاق وان في احداها عثرت على
اثار لمحتجزي اسرائيليين نحو 20 تقول انهم
كانوا محتجزين في ذاك المكان وقامت
بتدميرها بشكل كامل ميدانيا ايضا الجيش
الاسرائيلي عاد امس مساء ودفع بقوات ارتال
من الدبابات والمدرعات الى مناطق جنوبي
قطاع غزه ولكن دون تحديد ما اذا قد اتخذ
قرارا بخصوص توسيع عملياته لتشمل منطقه
رفح وكذلك ما يعرف بمحور فيلادلفيا وهو
الشريط الفاصل بين قطاع غزه ومصر وهو بعرض
40 مترا وتحيط به وطول
14 ونصف كيلو متر من البحر حتى منطقه كرم
ابو سالم وتحيط به اسيجه عاليه من حديديه
عاليه وتدعي بانه ما زال ميدانا لتهريب
الاسلحه والذخائر من مصر الى داخل قطاع ز